après cet examen très électrique hier
soir l'assemblée nationale du texte
sanitaire et ce rejet de cette mesure
d'un possible retour du pass sanitaires
aux frontières philippe bas est ce que
la majorité de droite sénatoriale
pourrait rétablir ce dispositif qui a
été supprimée par l'assemblée en tout
cas c'est le travail parlementaire senna
produira sa propre version du texte et
il faudra effectivement qu'ils se
prononcent sur un sujet simple important
mais qui n'est pas le pass vaccinale
pour aller au café au restaurant ou au
cinéma qui est le certificat de voyage
en quelque sorte ce n'est qu' au niveau
européen il ya un règlement qu déjà donc
ce règlement européen vous impose à voir
ce certificat pour pouvoir voyager en
europe si vous allez au danemark en
suède voulu l'utiliser la question se
pose donc hors europe qu'est ce qu'on
fait et je crois que si on explique
clairement les choses et si on fait un
petit peu de dentelle et qu'on
circonscrit bien le texte de la loi à
cette seule mesure faire en sorte que si
par exemple émergent quelque part dans
le monde un variant extrêmement
dangereux du coc vide on puisse faire
autre chose que d'interdire les avions
ou de mettre en quarantaine tous les
voyageurs qu'ils transportent le
certificat de voyage et ce seul
certificat de voyages qui montre qu'on
n'est pas contaminé ni contagieux est un
outil qu'on utilise en europe qu'il faut
pouvoir utiliser aussi dans certaines
circonstances avec le reste du monde qui
peut être d'ailleurs plus dangereux que
les pays européens parce que c'est pas
tellement dans les pays européens que
les variants du virus ont émergé et donc
gardons la sérénité nécessaire au bon
déroulement des travaux parlementaires
je réfléchis à une solution j'ai
interrogé le ministre ce matin qui est
prêt à une réécriture de son texte le
gouvernement n'est pas rigide
il est prêt à évoluer s'il évolue
suffisamment je crois qu'un chemin est
possible en tout cas mon rôle de
rapporteur la mission du sénat ce qui
n'est pas une chambre d'obstruction mais
une chambre de construction c'est de
réussir
servir l'intérêt des français en prenant
les bonnes mesures et en sachant aussi
les expliquer et le rôle du sénat c'est
aussi d'être dans une co-construction
responsable ir la première ministre
isabelle borne a fait référence au sens
des responsabilités du sénat vous
conférez si c'est une manière de le
reconnaître je l'en remercie c'était une
pression et si c'est une pression elle
peut s'en dispenser nous n'avons pas
attendu pour montrer notre sens des
responsabilités sommet vous que nous
avons obtenu des accords en commission
mixte paritaire sur nos amendements dans
78% des lois veut dire que ces lois ne
sont pas exactement celle qu'on aurait
voulu mais au moins nous avons obtenu
que nos amendements soient pris en
compte ce qui fait que à tout le moins
elles ont été moins mauvaises que si
elle sénat n'était pas intervenue et
parfois elles ont même été améliorée
donc notre travail c'est ça notre sens
des responsabilités l'avons démontré et
nous n'avons pas de leçons à recevoir
dans ce domaine c'est la treizième loi
sur le co vide que nous prenons cette
fois il n'y aura plus d'état d'urgence
sanitaire mais il reste à titres
résiduels quelques mesures pour les
voyages en avion et je crois que ces
mesures il faut les étudier calmement en
essayant de trouver de bonne foi des
solutions est ce qu'une mesure de
réintégration des soignants des
soignants non vaccinés une relégation
qui demandait en par les députés
d'opposition est ce que ce serait une
mesure pertinente dans ce texte mais il
faudra bien que ces personnels soit
réintégré le jour où
nous considérons sur la base d'avis
médicaux qu' il n'y a plus de danger
pour les personnes vulnérables d'être
soignées par des gens qui pourraient
attraper le virus donc je crois qu'il
faut mettre en place un dispositif
oui et on peut le faire dans ce texte
pour garantir à ces personnels de
pouvoir être réintégré le plus vite
possible compte tenu de la situation
sanitaire ce dispositif de l'intégration
ça peut être introduit dans le texte par
les sénateurs un dispositif permettant
de faire en sorte que dès que les
conditions sanitaires sont réunies ces
personnels soient effectivement
réintégrer
[Musique]